so I've drawn a circle here with radius
R and its center is at the point H comma
K so it's x-coordinate is H and its
y-coordinate its y-coordinate is K right
over here what I want to do is figure
out a general formula for the equation
of this circle in order to do that we
just have to remind ourselves that a
circle all the points on the circle are
the ones that are exactly the radius
away from the center their distance from
the center is exactly going to be R so
let's think about this a little bit what
constraints do we have to put on our X's
and Y's for them to be exactly R away
from the center so let's say let's say
that this right over here is one of the
points so this is X comma Y and this is
one of the points that is R away exactly
R away from the center so what's a
relationship going to be between X Y HK
and R and I could have put this point X
Y anywhere in the circle I could have
done it here as well this would also be
R away this is also going to be R away
from the center well it might not jump
out at you immediately but we can
actually use the Pythagorean theorem all
we need to do let's draw one going from
the center let's draw one segment that
is parallel to the x axis going like
this and let's draw another segment
starting at X Y that is parallel to the
y axis that's completely vertical so
this one is completely vertical this one
is completely horizontal so this is
going to be a right angle right over
here so if we can figure out the if we
can express the the height of this line
in terms of the variables we've just put
out and if we can express the height or
the width of this line right over here
in terms of these variables somehow then
we can relate those between at that and
are using the Pythagorean theorem R is
the hypotenuse of this right triangle
well what's this height going to be well
we know this point right over here has a
y-coordinate of K this point over here
well that just has a y-coordinate I
guess
good to say that has a y-coordinate of
why so this distance this distance right
over here is going to be the same exact
thing as this distance right over here
so it's going to be Y minus K Y minus K
Y minus K and what's this distance going
to be
well same exact argument this is H and
this point right over here if we go all
the way or this point on the x-axis well
we could just call that we'll just call
that X so what's this distance right
over here well this distance is going to
be X X minus H X minus H so what is the
relationship between this side of length
X minus H this side of length Y minus K
and R
what's the Pythagorean theorem the the
sum of the squares of the two shorter
sides is going to be equal to the square
of the hypotenuse so one of the shorter
sides is has length this has length X
minus H so I could write X minus H so
the side of the length of that side
squared plus the length of this side let
me do this in a color that I haven't
used yet plus the length of this side
squared so plus y minus K squared is
going to be equal to the hypotenuse
squared is going to be equal to the
radius squared and just like that we
have found the general equation of a
circle where H comma K where H comma K
is the center of the circle and R is the
radius any combination of X's and Y's
that meet this that for which this is
true given your Center given H and K and
given the radius then you that any any
kind any X's and Y's that are that will
meet these constraints are going to be
on the circle so another way you could
think about it if someone said hey look
I have a center the center let me write
it this way the center of my circle is
at the point I don't know five negative
five
and if they said that the radius the
radius is equal to four then we could
immediately say what the equation of the
circle is going to be it's going to be X
minus this right over here let me color
code this a little bit this right over
here is our H that's our H this right
over here is our K is our K and this is
our radius this right over here is our
radius so the equation of the circle
would be X minus H so X minus five X
minus five squared plus plus y minus K K
is negative five so if you subtract
negative five that would be the same
thing as adding positive five so y plus
five squared is equal to R squared well
R in the example I just made up is equal
to 16 so someone told you that the
center is at five negative five the
radius is four well this is going to be
the equation of the circle on the other
hand if someone gave you is gave you
this as the equation of the circle you
know that the center is going to be well
you have it's going to be at five it's
going to be at x equals 5 and y equals
and since this is a plus you know that
this is going to have to be and that
there K that the center is going to be
at five negative 5 5 negative 5 another
way to think about it is what are the X
and Y's that will make each of these
terms equal to 0 so if you have x equals
5 here then this thing is going to be
equal to 0 if you have y equals negative
5 then this thing is going to be equal
to 0
if you have a set if you had a circle
centered at at the origin at 0 then
you're going to have x squared plus y
squared is going to be equal to the
radius squared